elles se fondent dans le paysage aussi
naturellement que si elle avait toujours
été là depuis un an 13 cabane juchés sur
les chaînes autour du lac de bonal
accueil amoureux de la nature et
amateurs de vacances insolites
ce couple bourguignon vient de passer la
nuit niché à 9 mètres de hauteur ça rêve
d'enfant de d'avoir une cabane dans les
arbres et surtout pour le dépaysement
total
l'idée de la vie citadine qu'on a
actuellement les pollutions et tous là
on a une pleine nature
entrez entrez bienvenue dans la cave à
l'évasion
c'est une cabane pour deux personnes
vous avez ici un équipement ali équipé
d'une moustiquaire pour deux personnes à
l'intérieur des cabanes l'équipement est
rudimentaire pas d'eau pas d'électricité
des toilettes sèches et un chauffage
d'appoint
la direction précise qu'il est
indispensable de venir avec son sac de
couchage et son téléphone portable
chargé
le but c'est un petit peu de faire une
coupure par rapport à ce qu'on peut
vivre chez soi
et finalement on vit au rythme de la
nature on se couche quand il fait nuit
et on se lève quand il fait jour donc
c'est plutôt très agréable pour cette
famille belge la nuit dans les arbres
était une étape sur la route du retour
des vacances et les motifs de
satisfaction ne manquent pas la nature
fait d'être un environnement calme près
d'un lac en pleine nature régler pour le
chant des oiseaux où ça général
c'est paisible c'est relaxant c'est tout
ce qu'on vous recherchez en fait voilà
le petit déjeuner qu'on hisse soi même
dans sa cabane est compris dans le
forfait
117 euros la nuit par couple le prix à
payer pour être sûr de prendre un peu de
hauteur
pendant ses vacances